We spend most of our life working.
Therefore, it would be important that we learn how to deal with our daily problems at work...
...as well as in our private lives.
The author of the 2006 bestseller The Secret says that her new book The Power...
...will add a lot of new insights.
Byrne views life as either positive or negative.
She explains how our attitude and way of looking at things influence our reality...
...and how one can make bad aspects seem a lot better.
She writes, "No matter what negative situation you find yourself in,...
...you can always find something to be grateful for, and as you do,...
...you harness the force of love that eliminates negativity."
This mental outlook can, of course, be transferred to our working life, too.
When you spend most of your time at the workplace,...
...having a general change of mind can change your work attitude.